metro police are looking for the driver
who left a toddler critically hurt
following a hit-and-run crash sunday
night police say a three-year-old was
crossing doo little street when a white
van turned westbound on to doolittle
striking her then leaving the scene 80s
now reporter sally jeremy live near mlk
in lake mead she spoke to the family and
now shares more
denise and brian this all happened just
a few steps away from her home and
tonight her family is still in shock as
for that three-year-old treasure
breeland she is still in the hospital
tonight
around like 8 20 we was all outside we
were just
having a little halloween party for the
kids why would you draw that fast on
halloween with no lights on audra
edwards his truster relands on she still
can't comprehend why that driver didn't
stop we just hear a loud boom like it
sounded like he hit another car police
say three-year-old treasure was crossing
doolittle street when a white van turned
onto the street hit the little girl then
drove away like he hit one of the kids
he won the kid so we all started running
the driver stopped a little but then
went faster once he saw the adults we
don't know if it was a guy or a woman
but it was a
it was like a big
box being like a
they said it's a four so like it's a big
box being all white there was some stuff
flapping in the back of the windows
edwards says the street has a speed
limit of 15 miles per hour she says the
driver was speeding her message to that
driver to the person who did it you will
be found i mean you can't even say it
was the accident because why wouldn't
you stop you know what i'm saying you
just kept going you didn't care
out here live treasure is still in the
hospital as we just mentioned she has
gone through surgery and is expected to
be okay if you have any information on
that driver you are urged to call police
sally haramiyo live local now